Is there a detox supplement or regimen that is not hard on the kidneys?
I heard one doesn't want to overload the kidneys.
Well I would agree and the other thing that I would be careful with with a detox supplement
is making sure you're some all the phases of detox. So in school you learn that there's
really two, how many years ago you went to school, and now three phases of detox in the liver.
There's phase one, phase two in the liver, then phase three would be getting the detox
metabolites into the bile in order for it to carry into the gallbladder
and into the small intestine. I call that part phase four, and then carried through the intestinal tract,
I call that phase five, so they don't reabsorb it. So by needed it, that would be in my
phase five, and then phase six is getting it deposited into the toilet. So when you're talking about
a detox supplement, usually a detox supplement or a detox protocol is something that's going to either
keylate things out of the tissues, a key later, or a detox supplement or a detox protocol is supporting
phase one and phase two in the liver. Now I'd be okay taking, supporting phase one and phase two in the
liver, but still you want to make sure your phase six, making sure you have regular bowel movements,
your phase five, making sure that you're not reabsorb it, things that you're attesting still,
transit time is fast enough that you're not just reabsorbing things in the larger intestine that
your liver works so hard to jump into the bile, to dump into the smaller intestine,
now you're reabsorbing it into the large intestine. That's not a good thing. That's phase five,
making sure that your gallbladder is healthy enough to store and then dump that bile into the
small intestine. You don't have sluggish gallbladder, stones in there that you need to deal with,
and before I would make sure on those three, this is before I would start supporting liver,
or at least concurrently, whilst you're supporting liver detoxification in pathways.
And certainly you don't want to be using a key later pulling stuff out of the tissue before you
supported all those other pathways. That's what I call phase zero. So I don't think anybody has any
business, you know, pulling stuff out of the tissue until they've made sure all those other pathways
are nice and clear. That's what I call the seven phases of detox. You can download, you can watch
the videos on our blog post. I go into detail. I actually have a whole course of the seven phases of
detox in the book on it, but you can get the just of what I said on our blog post if you're
looking up seven phases of detox, I have to get created some videos on it too.